you know you have a camera or whatever
gadget and it doesn't quite work the way
you wish it did this is the beauty of
CES is that somebody is making an
accessory or another product similar to
your favorite gadget that does exactly
what you want this is Amber this is the
world's first temperature adjustable mug
for enjoying coffee at your exact
temperature cruise up the tool so it's
like a battery-powered mode basically
yeah but it has temperature control and
it keeps your coffee hot keeps it at the
perfect temperature how is this better
than one of those like insulated
Japanese thermoses that keeps your
coffee way too hot for seven hours so we
have a rapid cooling technology so it
actually cools your coffee down to the
temperature that you set and then holds
it there for hours on end does it do
that
we're using phase change cooling
technology embedded in the walls of the
mug to rapidly bring the coffee
temperature down to temp
then we use a tool van heating system to
hold your to cook your coffee up at the
temperature both the smart ball and the
smart feeder work with an iOS app or an
Android app and the butyl come out
dispensed from anywhere in the world you
can also do an on demand feeding if you
feed a dog that many skittles it's gonna
have a heart attack
yes what does this cause you call flower
power good power application to point
you know is this works in conjunction
with our parent tots which is a smart
lamp uh it has four different senses
moisture soil the temperature
surrounding the light that it's
receiving as well as it fertilizers you
were going on vacation for example and
we'll keep her plant alive for up to a
months
I kill so many plants already
what is what in the natural world is 125
decibels so a rock concerts about a
hundred decibels or maybe a ambulance
siren and is it just a speaker I can't
hear my amazement hold on so it's a
hundred and twenty-five decibels and how
many beers two cases two cases of cans
or bottles and swords twelve bottles of
champagne twelve bottles of champagne do
you have any demin do you have any
demonstration beers No